darf ich ihnen etwas anbieten
du hast kein wort gesagt auf der fahrt
her könnten wir das private bitte hinten
anstellen
ich möchte ja trotz allem einen guten
job machen den vertrag für den meister
ausrufen
warten wir noch unser fotomodell morgen
weißt du wo steckt der münchner halbe
stunde hier sein
nein ich weiss nicht berechtigt
entschuldigt
ich habe nicht durch einige bankauszügen
gequält und jetzt auf gefeiert geht um
den technik dienstleister menge nerven
gekostet ist die 2 das ist eher
ungewöhnlich oder nein
beim ersten mal mussten wir während des
aufbaus feststellen dass
veranstaltungstechnik müller einen teil
der technik nicht bereitstellen konnte
obwohl das vorher besprochen war dann
ist der andere eben schnell
eingesprungen und was genau hat edelweiß
technik nachgeliefert die gesamte
lasertechnik empa traversen und
projektoren
seitdem bekommen wir immer die neueste
technik zu einem fairen preis alle zwei
firmen arbeiten
konkurrenz belebt das geschäft das
leuchtet mir allerhand du leider kann
ich überhaupt keine referenz über
edelweiß technik im internet ich bin zu
spät
ich hatte vergessen das zu schnell hallo
schön dass du da bist du sagen wir
sollten keine zeit verlieren
hi dann kann's losgehen
lasst die finger von ihr was kann man
runter alter
was ist hier los
los geht's mist ich habe meinen
skizzenblock vergessen hast du
vielleicht noch ein für mich klar komme
einfach mit
tut mir leid dass ich dich erwarten
lassen
der vertrag liegt bereit sind weiß es
134.000 euro an ähnliche technik so
rasant dass hier alex events ich habe
eine frage was eine rechnung von ihnen
betrifft oder genauer gesagt welchem
umfang ihre technik dienstleistung hatte
ich habe hier nämlich keine genaue
aufschlüsselung der einzelnen posten
ich sage hier findet sich alles danke
meine rettung
so jetzt wird's aber zeit
das geht wird es heute noch ich bin
gleich wieder war